we like yes excellent good good
afternoon and so what we can talk about
for next hour is thinking outside the
synchronization quadrant which means I
have to say some meaningful things about
what I mean by that terminology and this
talk is placed in the ceaseless fast
track I would say that probably Hospital
relates to C++ specifically and the code
the code that I'm going to show you C++
some but the principles that I'm looking
at are actually far more general so so
it depends on what you're coming in for
there should be something here for you
and yeah code architecture architecture
good let's talk about architecture so
there are a number of different
definitions floating around the one that
I generally find the most effective the
most useful the most constructive this
is one from Grady Booch architecture
represents the significant design
decisions that shape a system where
significant is measured by cost of
change now this is very helpful because
it gets away from the false ideas of
scale what is the natural scale of
software unlike building architecture
it's not as obvious but there is a scale
here effort how much how much effort is
that to change very simple way of
indicating and discovering whether or
not something is architectural is
whether if you make a suggestion of a
change and somebody's face goes pale and
we can't do that or no no we never do
that if people say you can't do it then
its architectural okay and therefore
that means that it can relate to the
smallest language feature as well as
more obvious major technology choices
now one such thing that shapes the
system and is non-trivial to change it's
clearly something like concurrency the
presence of concurrency in any form now
one of the things I find interesting
about concurrency and parallelism and
our various definitions of all of these
is is the way that we have ended up
accidentally being programmed to think
in a particular way you can almost play
a word association game in fact this is
what I did a few years ago I did this
with into workshops I did play this word
association game and I got the same
results each time which I found
absolutely fascinating first idea that
comes into your head when I say
concurrency and as a room everybody said
threats so in other words what I found
interesting is that was with the the
junior programmers but in another
company with a whole load of advanced
developers who were Clint who actually
wanted to discuss higher order higher
level mechanisms it was fascinating if
you catch people off-guard threads are
how I didn't mean to say threads I'm it
say something like you know higher-level
and meaningful it's still in there it's
still deep down there threads are the
most powerful construct for introducing
concurrency in any code base and they
are powerful like a go-to is powerful it
was a an interesting proof in the early
1970s that go-to is the most powerful
sequential construct and what was meant
by power is you could build any other
sequential construct out of it and then
you have to throw the spider-man quote
at this point with great power comes
great responsibility and it turns out
we're not quite as responsible as we
thought we were the same goes for
threads you can build pretty much
anything else out of threading
constructs that it expresses concurrency
the problem is they are too primitive
they are too raw they are effectively
the jump statement at this level so we
acknowledge that there are going to be
threads but that may not be where we
want to write our code we want to leave
those further down
now the word Association does not end
there
because I threw another one at people I
said threads and they all said locks or
synchronization in other words that's
kind of interesting so hang on why are
you guys doing threading are we doing
threading because we want things to go
faster
why are you doing locking because we
want them to go slower well they didn't
say that but that's what they mean locks
are the anti threat the purpose of a
lock is to eliminate concurrency so if
your goal is to get some of these
then it's fairly clear whilst that may
give you it this take us away and this
is a a struggle that we often have
there's a lovely quote and I realized
I've just I just realized I've forgotten
to put it in this talk really from David
Boonton Hoff who wrote the book on POSIX
threads and he said you know what we
made a mistake calling them you Texas we
made a mistake adopting Eska Dijkstra's
terminology we should have called them
bottlenecks because then when developers
talk to each other and have a
conversation they're more likely to
think twice oh you need to put a
bottleneck in here mm-hmm
doesn't sound quite so good whereas
mutex has it's kind of like lovely width
of computer science about us yeah
bottleneck not so good okay so what we
realize is I'm going to pick on this
quote from somebody actually talking
about real building architecture
architecture is the art of how to waste
space but I know adapt it because when
it comes to code what we do realize it's
about the ability and skill of wasting
time so let's talk about this thing with
synchronization quadrant and actually I
found that some classified things simply
for a team a few years ago we went a
workshop on their on their development
practices and some of the issues they
were having and I found that one of the
simplest ways to clarify for them if I
split up on a flip chart and then
realize actually was a really useful and
classification mechanism this let's just
break them in a quadrant diagram first
of all it's the afternoon so your
metabolism your brain and everything
just gone into very has gone into a
sleep state so a quadrant diagram is is
your friend at this point it divides the
universe into four and there are two
axes and there are two things on each
axis it really doesn't get much simpler
than that and as with most quadrant
diagrams is only one quadrant that's on
a very very good or a quadrant that is
very very bad now I'm going to I'm gonna
break this one down to mutability there
is an axis immutability the data that
you are dealing with is either mutable
or it is immutable and then there is the
degree of sharing between threads your
data is either unsure
or chair now you can you can subdivide
this far far server you can say I've got
a single I've got a single writer and
multiple readers that's great that's
fine but that's over in the shared
quadrant I'm going to keep this quadrant
like and so here we have four places
your code can be I'm just going to make
this really really clear read nature's
color for bad or in Far Eastern cultures
and contractors colored celebration okay
this is the synchronization quadrant
okay you have mutable data and you have
state is shared between your threads you
will need some form of explicit
synchronization in your code okay I'm
not saying you don't need
synchronization anywhere else it's just
that the synchronization either belongs
lower down at the lowest level actually
we're in the processor or it belongs in
a library construct so there may be
synchronization it's just that we don't
want it all over your code so but there
is this thing but there's something
about this quadrant this is where most
code ends up living there are four
possibilities but like moths drawn to a
flame we are drawn our code bases are
drawn into this vortex in the top right
hand corner I'm and I have wondered
about this for a while and I realized
having I I I got a very very very long
time ago I got a master's degree in
parallel computer systems and so you
know you kind of think everybody knows
this stuff and actually turns out that
they don't and that you just happen to
be being exposed to all this good
knowledge and it turns out as the as we
tracked into the nineties and on we
ended up going into this quadrant over
here and I often wondered about this and
there's a simple cultural and historical
reason before threads became commonplace
all our code is on the left-hand side
because quite by definition you cannot
share between threads of you and you
have one thread so all
was over here and for historical reasons
are in our imperative background and
resource constraints and so on
everything was in the top left hand
corner a few things wandered down to the
bottom left but pretty much most code
we're talking about is in the top left
hand corner so when we added threading
as a language construct as a library
construct as a feature in the operating
system
we ended up naturally moving straight
over to the right with our code and that
led problem if you look at books that
are written in the 90s up until the
early 2000s whenever they introduced
concurrency they follow this idea
they're mostly about the locks how do we
lock stuff indeed a lot of the
literature published in the 70s and 80s
was along these lines about how do we
lock and all the constructs and proposed
language mechanisms are all in that kind
of view in the last decade or so we've
kind of really shifted it's not the game
that we didn't know that perhaps
avoiding all of these this locking
conversation was a good thing it's just
that it's become more normal and more
accepted so yeah we've ended up
unfortunately with a little flock of
code over there so let's talk about the
qualities of such code and when you're
dealing with a code when you're dealing
with code they're a kind of simple
right-hand rule that I quite like to use
the axes are not perfectly orthogonal
but then again neither of my fingers so
it's a good enough approximation but it
allows you to reason about code
reasonably simply and functional
behaviors operational behaviors and
developmental qualities okay so in other
words the functional and operational
qualities functional as in the semantics
the operational as in resources as in
what many people refer to as the illa
T's that are not related to the
development time the development time
stuff is your experience as a developer
most other to refer to runtime qualities
and if we look at those we can see that
obviously when you are improving
performance you're moving along the
operational axis when you are
refactoring you are maintaining a
constant functional axis but you are
trying to improve some developmental
quality and so on it's kind of an easy
way of kind of reasoning about your code
if you add functionality you move along
the functional axis
okay if you fix a bug you move along the
functional axis as well you know you had
a deficit of functionality now you make
up for it so it's a nice simple model
but I want to start first of all with
the operational axis this idea that the
qualities of execution are one of the
reasons that people are motivated to
introduce some form of concurrency into
their code um it turns out Shakespeare
was on this one as well I mentioned
Hamlet this morning for memory
management but he's here talking about
resources monstrosity and Lovelady that
the will is infinite and the execution
can find the desire is boundless and the
act a slave to limit we're going to come
back to limits again in a bit the
problem is you do not have the ability
to run things at infinite speed
everything has some kind of cost no
matter how brilliant you think your
architecture is it turns out this is the
point at which our beautiful
abstractions meet the laws of physics
and there are costs to the laws of
physics it's a rather good blog came
across recently link is at the bottom
what are the costs of various operations
from the kind of CPU perspective and
obviously this is going to vary from
processor to process and so these are
defined as ranges importantly it's
logarithmic I rather like the display
the idea of light how far does light go
travels during the time that this
operation takes clearly he has a smaller
laptop and me because it's not the
diagonal this one this is one light
nanosecond I often use that as a measure
when I'm telling people so I was
delighted see he's done the same thing
that's one light nanosecond which sounds
you know terribly fast until you realize
that gives you a cycle time effectively
that's the distance over there that's a
cycle time of one gigahertz which is not
so smart it's really you exhaust the
possibilities of one gigahertz in a very
short physical space and then he goes
through these are all of the magnitude
and the thing I want to draw your
attention to that context switch
that's generally more expensive in terms
of cost the raw direct costs lie between
a kernel call and a C++ exception throw
and catch
okay stack I'm winding the whole bit but
his he says in the article there's this
is quite difficult to measure because
there are loads of indirect costs that
go on you can and it turns out that
those can be ridiculously expensive this
is one of those things that and one of
the great disappointments people have
when they fire up threads hoping for
linear improvements what they suddenly
discover is they are not getting them
there's a cost involved there are lots
of cost effectively our coordination
costs so if we take the idea it's to
understand whether or not you want to
introduce introduced threading we take
this idea completion time for single
thread and we're working on some tasks
and the classic view of division of
labor I'm going to throw in threads at
this okay that's brilliant if everything
is independent and everything is for
free and if you remember at school you
probably did some projects of
electronics at some point and those is
rather brilliant assumption that was
made when you're first introduced to
electronics what is the resistance of a
wire that connects all your components
together zero I know it's not brilliant
you're at school and you get
superconducting wire how cool is that
yeah but it's a beautiful idealization
so this is the way that people often
think about threads it's just like we
end up with zero cost this is this is
fantastic even without worry about that
though we haven't even looked at the
nature of the task we are assuming that
everything is perfectly independent and
it's not going to be there is some
portion that you can do in parallel and
tasks have independence ease if they
need to talk to well on the share data
do whatever then there will be some
portion they cannot do in parallel so a
lot of it depends on on peak misses and
as well
we haven't even now we're going to get
rid of the ideal wires now it's quite
difficult to do this in a simple
equation so I'm going to I'm going to
give you worse case and over simplified
view but we get a shape out of it into
thread connections let's assume the
worst case that everybody needs to talk
to everybody else that is the absolute
worst case okay if you have that and
you're a contractor this is magnificent
you have a job for life okay but really
you don't want to be in this kind of
this kind of mess let's let's assume
that we've got some kind of concept of
an average communication overhead
average is a very difficult concept to
apply in this case but let's just say
we've got some kind of typical
communication overhead I think it's
going to give you a curve like this one
that basically means is the minute you
introduce threading into number of
minute you to find many tasks across
threads you get slowed down not knots
not Universal but people are often
surprised at how much benefit they do
not get this is the third this is the
first thing you need to remember it
turns out that if you don't have the
cost of a context switch then just being
able to do things really fast
sequentially turns out to be an absolute
winner we see this classically in the
sense that historically X Windows
servers sequential they use basic
reactor pattern and they just handle
something get on with it handle it get
on with it and they just do lots of
tasks very very quickly and there is no
need for concurrency the minute you
start hitting the concurrency barrier
you have to ramp it up quite a bit and
then you get something out of it and
we're not even worrying about whatever
else is going on in the processor
there's a whole load of other stuff
going on I'm just I'm just skimming and
lurking at the surface if you want that
Shores doing at all later
and he will talk more about stuff like
that unless you've radically changed the
slide since I last saw it so I'm just
scraping the surface here in terms of
the bits that you can easily do and
touch ok just with these constructs so
we have this and there's there is this
question of locality and cost the
landscape has changed as well every few
years we end up with a shift in our
architectural defaults the thing that
developers think oh that's so obvious
you always do that and it turns out it's
not so we're at this point Lovelace um
this is a blog from two years back and
Drake this very simple task command-line
tools can be over 200 times faster than
your Hadoop cluster and he basically did
this basically did this particular
number crunching task not particularly
big data but for some people it would be
Big Data obviously what we consider to
be big data as a function of time you
know once upon a time one megabyte was
quite big data so there is a point here
that people have got into the habit of
saying write distribute that you
distribute that across multiple
processors to the cloud with it to the
cloud with it
so we wrote this in Java and then he
wrote it again using Bourne shell and
ran it on a single machine because it
turns out the thing we now have it used
to be cheap processes across the network
turns out that memory is way way better
if you can keep it local do so you
cannot beat the speed of light it really
is it really is that simple
so this this is a key point we've got an
interpreted language here but because
it's able to use local memory brilliant
really benefits now speaking of that a
time to encode and do a very simple I
want to look at a couple of constructs
and what what is involved here and I
also want to place this on the
synchronization quadrant I'll give a
very simple kind of MapReduce approach
we're going to map some operation called
mapping across a number of tasks and
I've just realized I've got over did
that creating that live stuff you spot
the bugs and you can
fixa bucks you saw nothing okay Kenny
and that's good there you go right so
we've got an that and so then we end up
with a whole and choreography it's all
the sequencing is gone whereas that one
right there we go Castle I'm after
there's a whole load of noise that we
get from C++ in it's the kind of classic
form I've got my data from beginning to
end I've got a mapping operation mapping
I've got a reduction operation that's
going to combine everything with respect
to an initial value and then I'm going
to code this up raw by hand I'm going to
create a vector of threads and I'm going
to set up a loop where I go and launch a
thread we don't even know that this is
going to be appropriate we haven't even
looked at what cores are available and
you know I'm sure I'm going to hit the
threading really really hard here and
fire off each task and then I'm going to
wait and join on them and once I've got
everything joined at that point I can
combine everything I can use accumulate
accumulate is the standard library
default term for what everybody else
calls reduce or false so we've got that
okay um now there's a few things we can
do to tidy up here one of which is c++
14 I was going to just deduce the result
type and we're good with that the c++
concepts technical specification allows
me to get rid of all of that which is
marvelous
so that Tiny's it up a bit then if i
take on board the parallel technical
specification i can now get a parallel
version of full reach that can vectorize
I can give it a policy I can say write
vectorize that I've also got one for
accumulate that I can now do a reduce so
reduced it get spelt correctly at some
point and we've got that so if we look
here and relate that the bit that can
really I'm doing the reduce around doing
the reduction
I said well let's assume that we're that
our operation will actually work I'm
missing an argument in that I've just
realized will actually work fine one
particular point of view there is all
the concurrency that we can really
squeeze out of this is going to be the
for each bit the last bit most likely
better off done sequentially so in that
sense that code is from the point of
view of the synchronization quadrant the
first part assumes that nothing is
shared each piece of data is independent
therefore we're able to fire everything
off in parallel so there's no locking
there there is a synchronization point
at the end but that is hidden from us
and then again for the last point but
portion that can really be done in
parallel P is the first part okay
so there's another aspect to
functionality people often throw threads
at their code and because they want they
want to express functionality why does
that make sense
only as performance actually we use
threads for a very long time before we
got multi-core in fact one of the first
times that I was using threading was
definitely well well before the
multi-core era and our motivation was
quite different it was the expression of
functionality where where things are
independent I don't want to have to
write my own scheduler to make something
dependent I would like to be able to say
there's this going on and there's this
other thing feel free to leave them as
as a web so not getting true parallelism
but but some form of concurrency the
idea that I want decoupling between
tasks so from that point of view we're
saying threading not as a performance
gain but as a form of decoupling these
things are independent why should I have
to make them dependent on one another by
dividing up the tasks manually and
creating effective in my own scheduler
so there are motor there are reasons for
doing this however the expressiveness is
the bit that gets us and this is where
lurking in the top right-hand quadrant
causes us problems a large fraction the
flaws in software development are due to
programmers are not fully understanding
all the possible states their code may
execute it John Carmack of id games
in multi-threaded in a multi-threaded
environment the lack of understanding
and resulting problems are greatly
amplified almost at the point of panic
if you are paying attention in other
words we struggle to reason about states
in a code base we struggle more when
their state to change and then if we say
by the way things can happen out of
sequence and whilst your back is turned
then this is where the panic sets in and
if you do not have a healthy sense of
panic there is something wrong with you
you would not reach some Zen state yeah
there is something wrong with you if you
aren't dealing at this level it's like
there's a lot changing and there are
threats you need to take a very rigorous
approach to get away from that sense of
panic so it's most common example best
expressed here and say Myriad's of
concurrency city where Green pretty is
grasped the girls and are it's things on
our sequence we have the problem of race
conditions this is why people often say
yeah this is why I need locks the
problem is that we have this programmed
into us to such a degree that people we
people do not question why they have
locks and I have this conversation with
a group of the conversation was
interesting because I said why do you
have locks and they said because we have
threads and I said yeah but that's not a
reason why do you have locks
I can't looking at each other and they
said well yeah because because we got
threads and as well yeah because
otherwise it wouldn't be safe well why
would it not be safe why are you writing
unsafe code that's always a challenge
why are you making your code unsafe well
yeah because we're sharing data I said
yep you still have not given me a reason
why you're locking and they're kind of
looking at each other as if as if they
were my teenage son you know in other
words you're an idiot
yeah and then I said okay so what but
why does sharing stuff between threads
cause problems I said well because one
thread might change something and I said
well hang on wait a minute
that's really important that's the most
important thing you've said and you let
it to last that should have been your
opening sentence we've got changeable
state and it's being shared between
threads not we assume that all state is
changeable you should consider state
change to be a privilege not a right but
the problem is that the way we've talked
to program is the opposite way
and so therefore we fall into this
default way of thinking so there are
other surprises to be had when we start
showing lots of things locks mean
ultimately you go end up with deadlocks
and there's a really good summary of
some Tenenbaums
points and the site that found several
ways to address the problem of deadlock
just ignore it and hope it doesn't
happen this actually has a name it's
called the ostrich algorithm yeah it's
surprisingly popular and actually not as
ineffective as you would think
until you ramp up the number of states
your system could be in and the speed at
which it runs then it gets more exciting
and there are in turn there are also a
lot of systems that a lot of threaded
systems where these problems were India
started to happen with code that had
threads and been perfectly fine for
years but they've been single core they
hadn't actually they'd managed to
sidestep the actual issues and there are
some really subtle cases that that can
cause you these odd issues where well
let's just restart the server again you
know we have to do it once a month we're
not entirely sure why but there are the
words there are the ones that happen in
a far worse sense we have to restart the
server every minute is not viable so
this can work but I'm not going to I
wouldn't put money on it
detection recovery if it happens take
action so people spend a lot of time
coming with very clever techniques for
doing this dynamic avoidance by careful
resource allocation checks use of
resources granted enter data there and
so on so in other words this is kind of
an amplification of the previous point
but I prefer the fourth option
prevention change the rules yeah don't
don't play that game and sometimes
people do this by introduce imposing
some kind of law ordering or some form
of LOC discipline and basically saying
this code so as an art it becomes an
architectural guideline none of this
code has any locks this is the only code
that can have locks if you're going to
plug this code into this code here are
the rules if you follow these it all
will be good and it's a detectable thing
in other words there should be no
synchronization primitives and you're
only allowed to call with this object so
these become a
of conventions and architectural
guidelines rather than some happenstance
and accidents so yes we can do that and
we'll change the rules a little bit as
we go now I want to close this kind of
consideration with this last aspect of
developmental qualities one of the
developmental qualities when we start
saying things like threads at our code
when we start actually introducing these
low-level constructs creating high level
constructs what are we getting well what
would we want from one code one of the
things we want from our code is
habitability habitability is not a
common phrase that people throw around
code I've been very keen on using it for
the last years I first came across it in
this book by dick Gabriel patterns of
software in the late 90s and he makes
this observation very simple observation
we comply to any code based on any
language habitability is the
characteristic of source code that
enables programmers and so on people
come into the code later in life to
understand its construction and
intentions and change it comfortably and
confidently it's very simple idea it's
what we would define as habitability in
a home environment from a building you
want to arrive in a code base and
basically say yeah I want this to be
livable this should be constable place
for me to work in I shouldn't have to
sit there and go oh please don't send me
into that threaded nightmare
it should just be a case flight right
okay I understand what's going on this
is what we want in software developers
could feel at home they can place their
hands on any item without having to
think deeply about where it is that's
that's what we would like but what we
find in practice is a lot of threaded
code is in exactly the opposite place it
is uninhabitable you know it makes it
makes the rare vacuum of space seem like
a nice place
by comparison so how are we going to get
this well there are a number of
different qualities we want from such
codes testability is quite a nice one
quite fond of that one you'd like to
know something about how it works but
there are a number of misunderstandings
when we start talking about things like
unit tests sometimes people have
different takes on this and there are
different views now one of the ones that
I notice in a number of cases is where
people say well you know we can't really
afford the time to do unit tests we
don't find them particularly effective
sometimes that's
to be an indication of something deeper
in your architecture but I came across
this paper 40 years ago beginning of
last year came across it and then twice
more later in the year and it's rather
interesting analysis of certain
distributed open-source systems simple
testing to provide my most critical
failures looking at actual production
failures but the statistic that left out
at me is the they actually revealed that
something like 77% of the tests of sorry
77% of the problems could actually be
revealed with unit tests so over
three-quarters of the problems they
found could have been discovered the
unit tests you didn't actually have to
fire up the whole system in order to
discover these but that does lead to the
profound philosophical question you know
when people say we want our code to be
unit testable what do they mean and this
kind of an implied idea which is which
is quite difficult people tend to think
of their code like this if anything is a
unit test I think our only it's as fast
as it shows the code is correct
that's not what you get and assuming the
test is correct okay I'm going to give
you that one again let's assume the test
is correct that doesn't show you the
code is correct when you used to sales
it shows the code is incorrect it's the
other way and this is rather important
because sometimes people will it gives
you confidence but that's not the same
it's not the same measure and
particularly where you start doing
things concurrently you cannot assume
that green means it's good it just means
it's good so far you can be sure that
red is bad but green is a rigidly
defined area of doubt and uncertainty in
this case you have to be very cautious
with it it's a level of confidence but
it's not absolute confidence and there
and the law of the excluded middle does
not apply here it's quite important to
keep keep in mind how do we achieve this
watch what helps us with testability
what helps us get away from that idea of
like well I can't really test it because
the architecture is so sophisticated
well actually is not it's probably a
lack of isolation isolation allows the
code
to be testable but there's something
else there's something far more
important that isolation allows you to
reason about it
we are surprisingly good at reasoning
about certain things as long as they are
isolated from others but humans can be
easily flooded with too much connection
when you have to take in take on board
too much you will not cope with
everything you will overlook something
so there's this idea the more we are
able to isolate things the more we are
able to reason about them in confidence
this is why people bang all about
modularity fur and have been doing so
for decades it's not for mathematical
elegance it's actually the fact it
respects you being human
other qualities that may help us
immutability is one of those things that
helps us things being in sequence it
turns out we're really good with this
happens then that happens then the other
happens but that is at one level it
feels like it's at odds with our desire
for concurrency but we are good at
reasoning sequentially and one of the
ways that we can reason about this and
kind of have the best of both worlds is
by the introduction of a synchrony but
obviously not everything that is
asynchronous is easy to comprehend
hasn't my favorite one recently ten
things you'll find shocking about
asynchronous operations beautiful just
one of one of the best I've come across
in terms of it captures it captures it
rather elegantly so there is this
question if I take operations that are
synchronous and I would like to make
some asynchronous what do I have to be
aware of well I'm sure there's a
question of ordering how I pick up
results and we talk about futures
imposer for immediately returned a
virtual data object a virtual proxy
effectively called the future also known
as an IOU to the client when it invokes
a service this future only provides a
value to clients from the computation is
complete now you can take future based
computation a very very long way I
propose not to close I know that sure
we'll be talking about that way way more
deeply and I'm going to but I'm going to
introduce the basic concept here we do
this sequentially we get a result from a
function now if we want to do something
after it that is independent then we've
just forced forces into an unnatural
sequence there's a thing I want to do
call the function
another thing that I want to do and then
I probably want to combine these things
later I could switch them round but same
issue so what we do is we separate the
stuff out and we say okay let's launch
the function asynchronously I'll pick it
up as an IOU I'll go and do other stuff
when I actually need the result then
I'll go get it
this is the kind basis of where we can
start taking certain days flow ideas I
will interject at this point though I
think the C++ 11 syntax for this sucks
completely I had a model that I
published a number of years ago actually
made into proposal form where I decided
that what I said basically everything
should be a function and we should
follow uncle and the idea is that a
future is effectively a thread or is
effectively a function object thread is
a verb you take a function and you
thread it it is not a singie it is a
verb that you do to something what you
get back is something that allows you to
join it and pick up the result and
everything is done as a function you
thread things using functions the result
of calling one of those is itself a
function if you want the value then that
is itself a function so you can use that
wherever function objects are expected
you can extend this model quite quite a
lot so it's quite a regular one of fits
with the C++ style this whole get thing
doesn't really appeal to me well that's
that's a binder by but there is a
there's a kind of an idea there that
these ideas there's a these practices
have been around for a very long time
and people have got different ways of
expressing them in different languages
have different ways of expressing them
but if we go beyond go beyond the future
it sounds very dramatic if you go beyond
the future on a pickup on this general
observation from Russell winder instead
of using threads and shared memories our
programming model we can use processes
and message passing process here just
means protected independent state with
execution code not necessarily in our
ass process now we have a lot of
terminology collision we sometimes refer
such systems is message passing but it
turns out we've ended up with lots of
terminology for the same constructs and
supple shades and variations between
them which I'd like to explore but
Russell points to two things languages
such as Erlang and Aachen before it
Erlang uses the answer model and akhom
uses something called CSP have shown
that processes
a very successful mechanism for
programming concurrent and parallel
systems and such systems do not have all
the synchronization stresses that shared
memory multi-layered systems have more
importantly they do not have the
reasoning challenges that such systems
have in other words the code is very
localized it feels very sequential it
has this idea and this is an idea I
guess I've been pushing for a while by
various names it allows you to think in
a sequential bubble I said that
sequential reasoning is something we're
quite good at what you want from your
code is that each part of the code is
sequential and has no idea about the
world of concurrency the construct of
threads or anything like that in essence
it becomes the idea that any piece of
code you write is therefore more easily
testable because it itself is sequential
and simply reasoned the idea is that you
then through a compositional approach
whether it be wiring whether it be
coordination language or something else
you then say and here is where we
introduce the concurrency we take our
rather simple modules and wire them
together but there is this idea that
wherever you are the world should look
sequential and if you're getting data
then that data arrives as if it were
events or it arrives because you pull it
from a channel of some kind but you
don't have the idea of I am interacting
with another threat you try and avoid
that kind of structure in one sense this
is what can be called a virtual
uniprocessor for a number of number of
decades computer science spent a lot of
time talking about virtual
multiprocessor I think how to give the
illusion of parallelism on a single core
whereas virtual uniprocessor is you've
got massively parallel hardware and you
like to give the illusion of sequential
reasoning math term was first applied to
the best of my knowledge to describe the
human brain we have this beautiful
illusion of a stream of consciousness on
this ridiculously parallel hardware and
it turns out that's not a bad way of
thinking about stuff so you want your
code to have that kind of feel to it and
these models generally give that
generally give that kind of feel so the
most fundamental constructs about queues
for a moment
cube are you got producers you've got
producer there you've got a consumer
there you've got a queue in the middle
so the producer and the consumer
represents activities that are decoupled
from one other with respect to time most
and the most obvious concept of time in
this case I'm talking about is threading
but decoupling through time is what
we're talking about I can actually have
a perfectly sequential system where I
have a producer producing into a queue
followed by a piece of code in the same
thread that unpacks that queue as a
consumer so the idea is when we say
decoupling through time that can mean
true parallelism it can actually mean
we've ordered things sequentially or
we're doing things by a time trigger or
whatever the idea is that we're trying
to create a model that almost doesn't
care some level so this is a simple
one-to-one relationship this guy's
giving something maybe is doing i/o this
guy's doing something else yeah fine now
that's the simplest arrangement you
could find we're going to come back to
it later what you may find is that
you're taking things from lots of
different sources there are lots of
different places you can be getting your
input from or alternatively these these
guys are these guys are running at
different speeds and therefore you would
like to pace them so you've got an end
to one arrangement here or it may be the
other way round and there may be a
logical thing maybe you've actually got
ports out here so on that you want to
send things through so there's reasons
either physical oh and that physical or
physical physical in the sense of
communications or physical in the sense
of time so you can decouple them like
that now that's an N 2 1 and a 1 to n
arrangement you may also find what I
would generally recommend that the end
not be the same on both sides m to n you
may find that it makes sense to
serialize things there may be a lot of
stuff coming in on the left-hand side
again io rather than computational tasks
body makes more sense for this
arrangement and on the right-hand side
and you want some kind of fan-out to
different tasks and other configurations
use more than one cue okay and likewise
on the other side and then obviously I
guess
generate cases where you realize
actually you've just got a one-to-one
arrangement just lots of it okay so you
can keep combining these and crossing
over you can have one thing posting to
lots of queues and lots of things
picking up on the other side there's
lots of arrangements I could just keep
copying and pasting this slide to
generate all of them but the idea here
is the queue is most general construct
at this point for decoupling in time and
there's performance and characteristics
of your system that will dictate which
configuration you are interested now
from a code perspective which Y and Y
and summers together and then get a feel
for what this might look like if we
create a queue of anything so make it
generic so we've got a template there
I'm going to start with the simplest
ideas that I can send something and I've
got a choice of it receiving it I'm
going to do this as a non-blocking
receive try receive I can pick up a
value if there's nothing there to
receive then I will return false and if
somebody's trying to invite a fume then
I've got a very simple locking mechanism
well let's do it sequentially first if
there's nothing there then I'll get back
false I'm just going to use the standard
library deck type so that's going to
nice and easy from that point of view if
you send you just pushing back and if
you try well if you try and receive if
there's something there we do something
with it otherwise we don't it's as
simple as that we return false
so that'll works rather nicely and it's
profoundly not sequential or rather
family not concurrent in any way shape
or form not safe so we reach for our
bottleneck throwing a mutex and we say
okay now we can start sharing this
between arbitrary number of senders and
receivers and that allows us that and
this works quite nicely for the non
blocking approach and this may be
sufficient this may be what you want and
so we use a scope lock to ensure that we
have a critical section of automatically
lock and also exception safe and we
can't do the same on the other side but
now we've got two reasons why we may
fail to return a value previously was if
I try and receive and there's nothing
there I return false here there's now
another reason I tried to receive an
either there was nothing there or
something was being something was being
put in at the L
and now if you know more about the
characteristics of your system then you
can start separating locks for your ends
but I'm writing the most generic form of
Q here I cannot assume that the ends are
always going to be far apart I cannot
make certain assumptions in this case
but I'm giving you something that
reasonably works reasonably well so
that's the basic construct now the next
thing we might want to put in is a
receive that is a blocking receive
sometimes we don't actually want to do
anything else there is nothing more for
this thread to do I don't want to just
sort of thing I tried to receive and I
failed what do I do now I'm going to
spin lock now that's probably not a good
idea
perhaps this task exists only to work
with values so there are further layers
we can put on this but I'm going to
leave this at a fairly raw Q level but
we're still hiding the lock I want to be
able to block on that receive until I
get something now we could go further so
I'm gonna have a throw in a condition
variable there we could go further and
also have a try received now I'm going
to make a point here I'm not going to
explore it much further than this
because I did mention the Shakespeare
quote everything is a slave to the limit
you don't really want a cue like this in
production code for the simple reason
that there's no bound on the Q if
something goes wrong
if you if something goes wrong you've
not anticipated it you can use up all of
memory which is really not what you want
this Q can fill up to infinity or the
amount of memory you have available
whichever comes sooner and I think I
have a pretty good idea which one's
going to come soon the idea is you can
end up with if you end up with a locked
receive if you end up with a locked
receiver and you're still sending
thank-you is just going to pile up so I
people care about Q links and production
code so really you actually need to have
the idea of a bounded queue these are
great for prototyping things and they
will work fine at certain classes of
system but either you have to have a
hidden hidden constant or you need to be
able to parameterize it yourself so now
there is a maximum size for this we are
not going to let this grow until all of
our resources have been exhausted and
you can choose to embed that within the
Q constructor or put it somewhere else
but it has to exist somewhere do not
assume that they should be unbounded in
production code however its keep things
simple I'm just going to save like this
don't worry about that I've talked about
the bit that sort of there's a heads up
there but the next thing is yes and Cody
I'm already going to worry about that it
just does the right thing we've got a
condition variable we'll continue
blocking or suspending while there is no
content to receive and when they're
finally is we'll actually do something
and I should pop the result now there's
a few other bits and pieces that we can
start adding in to refine the code I'm
not going to worry about those I want to
go back to the idea that we've got a
basic functioning queue I want to go
back to an idea that earlier on I
mentioned we'd be coming back to the
one-to-one case there is a particular
name the idea of queue is that we can
have a queue allow many too many
one-to-one one-to-many many-to-one a
channel is a special case a channel is
we borrow the terminology from CSP
communicating sequential processes it's
a single point to point of contact go
also uses the term channel like these
perhaps not as strict it really just
means queue at one level but it borrows
some of these ideas but strictly
speaking if we have a channel it is it
is there is one sender one receiver has
a dedicated line of communication it is
a dedicated queue which allows certain
simple optimizations I can have a
channel I can just basically say that
queue that I just showed you
I'm going to go with that or
alternatively I can create something
else as a channel and have some rather
clever low LOC implementation that takes
advantage of our known limits in the
fact that there's only one there's only
one sender and one said we can start
taking advantage of this knowledge
whichever one we do I'm just saying that
the configuration I'm interested in here
is this one so there is this dedicated
receiver so we're going to take a you
know one of those great problems of a
software developer development of tanks
is everybody's minds and imaginations
fizzbuzz
and is it not exactly the hardest
problem in the world ms I'm not going to
look at clever ways of paralyzing it I
just needed something for the code to do
so here is the thing for it to do the
number de visite is divisible by 3 & 5
you get fizzbuzz by 3 fees by 5 buzz
otherwise just get a string aside form
of the number that's it that's there's
nothing interesting parallel or whatever
about this that's not what I want I just
wanted something to chew on
so parallel e bit comes in here what
we're going to do is going to have a
going to set up a physical server
because that's what everybody needs
it's called sous buzzer okay what is
going to do is going take an input
channel it's going to main output
Channel on the input Channel we're going
to see vintages on the output Channel
I'm going to send strings nice and
simple so now from this point of view if
we look at this piece of code there's
absolutely nothing sequential or there's
nothing parallel or nothing can Carolla
about this piece of code it is a you
know I'm just basically taking in a
channel and another channel I'm going to
use both of those I'm going to just run
around and do stuff that's fine so this
is actually quite easy to test I'm going
to set up main we're gonna have a
channel out the channel back we're going
to launch that as a separate thread I
don't have to and there's actually
nothing here interested but I'm gonna go
and send something and then I'm going to
get back a result and I'm going to print
it out really nothing nothing exciting
going on here I can resequenced in tax a
little bit and make it feel a little
more c++ e but what's more interesting
here is i'm able to decouple and have a
thread that's out there waiting for
stuff send it a whole load of requests
and the other channel with the return
channel a back channel is now full and
then i pick up the results separately so
now we actually introduce something some
slightly more meaningful concurrency not
particularly meaningful but the idea
here is i'm able to rearrange the code
from that point of view the channel
concept a specific out and back approach
is a really simple way of decoupling
pieces of code it allows me to actually
fill up stuff prime something for
testing so something like they are
mocking it well I'm not mocking
- I'm just simply giving it a pre-loaded
cue I can get rid of and rearrange this
relatively easily as a matter of wiring
it doesn't mean you can't get deadlocked
yes you can but it means that it's now
down to the wiring rather than the core
logic that's going to give you that and
it's anything else oh man that's that's
vessel if his mother is going to do so
in renewed syntax so let's look at a
particular application and again the
terminology pipes and filters is really
built on channels but we talked about it
slightly different again a pipe is the
idea of a dedicated point-to-point piece
of communication very powerful from a
general point of view in terms of
thinking about composition we divide
applications tasks in several
self-contained data processing steps
connect these steps to a data processing
pipeline firing immediate data buffers
we see the pipes and filters model
allows us the introduction concurrency
but it also allows us expressiveness we
find that many people you can see in the
Java streams model without introducing
concurrency it's a very profound and
useful way of reasoning about a task
because it is based on a functional
programming model a lot of people don't
realize this but this rather good point
was made by John Purdy a couple of years
back concatenated programming is the
style its relies on function composition
rather than function application and
this is the basic reason UNIX pipes are
so powerful they form a rudimentary
string raced I can cancel into
programming languages a very simple idea
each step is a compositional step you're
going to take data you go process it
you're not going to worry about you
don't introduce side effect on the data
because you parse on new data something
else and it's a particularly different
style of functional programming it
should that is not the same as a classic
applicative approach and there's a lot
of benefits to that without concurrency
but in a thread some concurrency on it
so I'm going to pick on a very simple
idea we've got here is we have some kind
of source and the arrangement is that we
have a filter then we can maybe have
another filter and then we have a
I think and they're connected together
using these pipes I pick a not
particularly meaningful problem although
this is one of those ones that came out
of in a rather interesting conversation
about Friday the 13th
we had a Friday the 13th last week so
now this seems they're timely if you are
superstitious then we should have a
proper conversation but that's nothing
to do with C++ if you are superstitious
then you fear Friday the 13th then you
might sit down and write some code to
decide when the next Friday the 13th is
you might do this in a kind of Rossi
approach we're going to move this to C++
and not a lot of change actually they c+
stuff chrono library actually if I were
to port this to that I would end up
using more keystrokes so I'm not going
to do that I'm going to just leave this
with the raw stuff this will find you
the next the next Friday the 13th after
the one that you prefer the date that
you provide so so this is this is all
good now not so what we're gonna do is
going to break this one down instead of
expressing the logic stead of expressing
the logic this way I want to find I want
to get a steady stream of finding the
13th and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to turn this into a pipes and
filters arrangement I can start off like
this so I'm going to say right first of
all we need to generate all the days of
interest you give me a date and then we
will just generate we will loop forever
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to filter here I'm going to select in
the 13th of every month ok so this is
how we did this is a simple way of doing
and with pipes and filters ok what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to include in
select in every 13th month and now I'm
selecting all the Friday's when I get
out is a steady stream with Friday the
13th switch I will then display so I
broken it down into a pipeline and so
we're going to wire this up we're going
to have a channel for all the days and
we're going to arrange this so that the
days are from the start yeah
unfortunately the outline here it's got
bleached out by the projector will have
days from the start will wire it into
the today's and that's just going to go
on forever actually they don't go on
forever
- they will hit a limit it turns out
disappointingly we're not allowed to
compute to infinity on this but you know
what we're going to do is just keep on
looping generating days and move forward
a day at a time
then we'll wire up the next bit by
saying okay you give me all of those
days that's the input and then I'm going
to give you the output which is only the
13th so I'm going to just select in read
a day if it's a 13th then I write it out
otherwise I'm not going to then the next
one I only want the Friday's and we wire
that one together and then finally we
actually display it and we pick that
stuff up so there's a nice little
pipeline progression there that will
give us all the Friday the 13th of
interest and there is a simple idea here
we can actually we can rearrange there's
a few things that we can rearrange we
can actually I've done this in a more
classically CSP style in the sense that
what I've done is I've created functions
that take channels it is possible to
invert this relationship and say here's
a channel and I'm going to associate
behaviors with its ends which is a sort
of an inversion of the model that I've
got here but I'm going to leave that one
to one side there's quite a lot that you
can do with this once you start down
this road so there's sort of an elegant
sign to that if your architecture fits
that that's great you know very easy to
reuse far easier to compose and work
with some other pieces of code but there
are most interactions that we want to
probably introduce threading into don't
really fit a pipeline model one-way data
flow we might need some interaction and
at this point this thing that I did many
years ago for my master's thesis was
extra base systems though one of the
things I worked with was a language
called ABC L actor based concurrent
language or an object based concurrent
language depending on which version you
read and when we talk about raw
multi-threading other Alexandros whose
quote is one of my favorite ones
multi-threading is just one bad thing
after before simultaneous with another
but what is acted based computation acts
based concurrency is just one bound
message after another you
are in the sequential bubble everything
is sequential you just receive something
you handle it you pass it on but that's
obviously doesn't have a unique claim to
that so let's have a look at one of the
classic approaches which is monitor
objects the monitor object is the way
that Java decided to bake into the
language every every object is
essentially a monitor object which means
that it can be it has a lock over the
whole object and it can be synchronized
every method can be synchronized or part
of the method can be synchronized in
execution and there is a locking scope
it's the idea of passive data objects
that have such synchronization built in
so that's great because that shouldn't
be our code should be somebody else's
code but and it is very lock based and
it doesn't work well in a compositional
sense but it can be okay to write and if
we imagine something like a phone book
on which we're going to provide basic
operations and update operation for
somebody's name and number a drop
operation to drop an entry and a find
operation that optionally returns a
string and nothing's there so optional
it is now 2017 optional is now finally
in the seaport will be in C++ 17 so that
saves all those null things or using
empty string as a marker so basically if
we find the name and it's there we get a
result if we don't then we're told that
we don't have a result and this is in
optional appears in other languages
sometimes called different things
fallible may be and so on
so got that structure we're going to
have a simple mutex model like we had
earlier on and we can go ahead and we
can build this stuff up we can update
it's an upset operation we can drop and
then we've got the find operation so in
action what we're going to end up with
is something like this we create a
directory so we have our phone book in
another thread we go and look for thomas
anderson tom stands and is not yet in
the phone book so we've got an updating
thread so we've got two threads of
interest here the FIR the directory
thread is actually passive we're going
to go and update that next time we try
find Thomas Anderson in the in another
thread both of these operations will be
ordered in some way and mutually
exclusive so therefore we are guaranteed
of some kind of coherence and we will
get some value we go and look for neo
neo is not in there we're not date with
Trinity we're going to date Morpheus we
can update with we haven't dropped on us
and so we're going to add neo now we're
going to find Thomas Anderson but what
we found but neo will be and because he
is the one so we've got a simple model
there so monitor objects are very
attractive and very simple at that level
there is another approach which for
reasons of time active objects we could
go into but I'm going to leave that out
for your comfort but I wanted to put
them in there why am i showing you
something in saying I'm not going to
show you it I'm putting that in there
because a lot of people confuse active
objects and actors they are not the same
programming model they are potentially
related but they're not the same
programming model the actor model has a
different outlook the actor model I'm
going to show you a full Actimel I'm
just going to build an apathy a build a
very very very basic version out of the
Q construct and the standard library
thread we had earlier also in C++ 17
will be standard any a variant type
there are actually two variant types
this is a universal variant type and
what I'm going to do here is the phone
book you'll notice I've changed it into
a function it is what we're going to do
here is we're going to bind it together
we're going to say look here is your Q
you have an Associated Q and anybody can
talk to you using this Q we can be more
specific about the message set but I'm
going to leave it as open and generic
message set here I'm going to say well
you can have an entry I mean you're
giving an entry or you're receiving an
entry in other words it's a name and a
number you can have a no entry in either
you or telling the phonebook please I
don't want this anymore all you're
returning this entry does not exist and
you can have a find request here is a
name and here is the return address
please send it back on this Q okay so
there's the idea that somebody can talk
to a running function
that is that is the basis of the anthem
model it's not that we are creating a
classic object and putting locks in it
it is that we are creating a function
and we are now communicating with a
running function this function it
doesn't reveal its own state its private
state really is private its local
variables if I might actually have a
look at that here is phonebook
here is the scope it's going to get a
bit Messier you can tidy this up but I
realized that for reasons of time well
that's really what this whole talk is
about isn't it time
temporal decoupling but for reasons of
time I'm not going to go into the
details of it so I'm going to do the
kinds of raw ugly almost assemble like
version but show you the the basic
construct here is the private state this
was previously private actually private
within an object but this is now just a
local variable the function is just
going to keep on requesting I'm not
going to put any termination it's just
going to loop forever or ctrl C and the
only operations that it can do is to
affect entries there's no there's no
kind of clever thing that somebody can
do to get their hands on your private
state that is the private state entries
so now we're just going to repeatedly
handle requests we would pick up a
request
now comes the ugly bit is I now have to
go and do it in a type dispatch this is
the bit that you can tidy up with a
little bit of a [ __ ] a poker but what
we're going to do here is we're going to
pick up is it an update how I received
an entry if it's an update then my
update I update the entries with update
name and update number on the other hand
is it a drop request am I being told no
entry if it's a drop request and I will
erase that entry if that's the case but
the bit that is interesting is a notice
neither of these requires interaction
when another thread another actor is
basically communicating with you say I'd
like to add this entry or please drop
this entry they're not expecting a
response it's it's a synchrony without
any kind of blocking return there's no
futures involved they're doing this now
we need to talk to somebody and that's
where the find is quite a good example
something's going to send us a fine
request please find us Nia or Thomas
Anderson or whatever if the entry is not
there we need to
well somebody it was not there if the
entry is there we need to tell somebody
we need to talk back in this case the
return address is useful an important
thing that is often overlooked in actors
is you don't have to actually return the
call to the caller you do have to return
the result of the caller what they can
do is they can set this up and this is
perfect decoupling I'm going to make a
request of you you talk to that guy over
there okay it's not an actual return
address it's a really a forwarding
address and it may come back to the
requester but it may go on to somebody
else so what we're going to do here is
we've got this if it's if it's not there
we're going to use the cue that was
given to us and say look there was no
entry on the other hand if it is there
there was an entry so what we've got
here is a proper message handling loop
but all baked into constructs that are
now available in the C++ library plus
the Q construct that I added in earlier
in execution that's going to the call
we're going to move away from the idea
that we're dealing with functions we're
going to do something that's a little
more message like so I'm going to set up
a directory then I'm going to launch a
thread that holds the phone book with
the directory and then I'm going to say
right okay I've got a Q and I would like
to find Thomas Anderson please return it
here we're not going to find anything so
I'm going to pick that results up and
what I should get back is no entry
Thomas Anderson in another thread we're
going to have an updating thread as
we've actually got three threads running
here we're going to have something
updates with Thomas Anderson one back in
the requesting thread we're able to now
find it we pick up a result and that
should be the result that we get and we
can go through at Trinity Morpheus
dropped on the Sanderson and add neo
because he's the one and we can now find
neo and we get that back and what we've
done there is that man is the the raw
ingredients if you like this is the
actor model broken down to its most
fundamental level and clearly with a
little bit of imagination and if you
could experience of mental models in
other languages you can immediately see
the opportunities
wrapping that up but just based on a
q-and-a thread we can actually affect
this model and a note where it goes and
what style it gives us that our messages
become first-class objects rather than
methods can we get this in version that
the function itself becomes a running
object that we communicate with okay so
sort of bring that to a close there's an
awful lot in there and it's definitely
coming for a coffee bar go go back John
Carmack instead yeah it's a point there
is that what we've ended up with is a
number of things that are actually
relatively functional in their nature
function style makes the state presented
to your code explicit which makes it
easier to reason about and in a
completely for your system makes thread
race conditions impossible the idea is
that we are explicitly not thinking
about I have data that I wish to share
we are thinking about there are things
to be done who do I talk to and that
kind of approach isolates a service it's
a slightly different philosophy but
using the same basic language you went
with a very very different architecture
and one that is more composable
so hopefully the one thing we've learned
about thinking outside the
synchronization quadrant is that our
default desire to put locks around
everything when we care about speed is
going to be sorted because you know the
thing you always have to keep in mind is
is all computers wait at the same speed
and this is the problem that we've been
encountering as people been trying to
scale things up what they've learnt is a
number of lessons sometimes the hard way
and particularly now that we are moving
from at the moment I would sense that
we're moving a little bit back from
operating system processes to threads
because we've discovered we have a
remark when out of memory available this
is worth keeping in mind and not to say
oh now I'm in the same process I can
just go back to my old see like ways of
sharing everything and just having locks
no the lessons that were learnt pushing
things out where you genuinely couldn't
share them those are valuable and worth
keeping in mind I hope that's been
useful I'm around for any questions as
I'm unpacking please feel free to ask
thank you